ليه 227 عاما بعد تاسيسه ظل الكونجرس
الامريكي الذكوريه الحضور والتمثيل حتى
اخترق جدرانه صوت انثوي تمثل بعضويه جان
ترانكلين عام
انجاز غير مسبوق حققته لنكن كاول امراه
تدخل لاروقه الكونغرس حامله بيدها صوتا
يمثل النساء اللواتي دعمها للترشح والفوز
بالمقعد حيث انتخبت ممثله الحزب الجمهوريه
عن ولايه مونتانا بعد عملها للسنوات
كناشطه حقوقيه ومطالبتها بحق الانتخاب
للمراه الامريكيه
عقب وصولها لمجلس النواب باربعه ايام شكلت
الصوت الرافضه لدخول بلادها غماره الحرب
العالميه الاولى مفضله الحياد وذلك بعد
تقدم الرئيس ودرو ويلسون بمشروع لاعلان
الحرب على المانيا غير ان
373 نائبا صوتوا لصالح الحرب لتاتي
الاصوات الخمسون الاخرى ومن ضمنها صوت ركن
خجوله ركن وصلت اثناء بقيه فترتها
كبرلمانيه الدفاع عن حق الانتخاب للامريات
كما دعم التمريره بعض القوانين الاجتماعيه
لصالح المراه والطفل لكن التصويت ضد الحرب
اغلق مصيرها السياسيه فشلت بالترشح لمجلس
الشيوخ عام
وغادرت مجلس النواب بعد عام واحد
شعبيه ترنكن بالساحه النسائيه اخذتها
برحله ثانيه الى الكونغرس عام 1940 لتصطدم
حين هكذا بقرارات مصريه التزمت فيها مجددا
بالسلميه لا اخرى على قرار دخول الحرب ضد
اليابان اثر الهجوم على بيرول هاربر
حاله استثنائيه شكلتها
تفردا تصويتها ضد كلتا الحربين لكنها كانت
لتصبح اكثر شرا لو اعطيت وقت اطول وقتلها